you're hearing it on both
sides everybody's talking about how the
other side is corrupt
who do you believe and what methods
should be taken for these guys to be
held accountable
uh i think it's a great question i think
what we're seeing in the country today
the political tumults on the left right
and center
is precisely to your point uh the fact
that there is distrust
i don't think there's distrust in the
system as much as there's a distrust
in the leadership and how they have
manipulated the system
i think a lot of people recognize that
that you know the founding
fathers gave us this this powerful
system that diffused power
uh that made sure that power would not
be concentrated they
like that system the problem is that
that there is in a sense
a consensus in washington dc a lot of
people don't realize that
there's a consensus in washington dc on
these corruption issues what do i mean
uh what i'm saying is that
bipartisanship is not dead in washington
most people on the on the right and on
the left
that are in positions of authority in
washington dc
generally agreed to the ground rules of
how
what i call legal graft occurs in
washington they accept the fact
that members of congress have family
members that are lobbyists
even if they're not qualified and that
those family members get paid
uh because of the position of authority
that their mother or father might have
as a member of congress
um they all know it's corrupt but the
ground rules are such that they
all are benefiting so there's a
consensus that's emerged they don't talk
about it
so what you have is you have of course
red states and blue states in america
what we also have is really the rest of
america
against the washington beltway um and
that i think is
underappreciated and i think one of the
reasons that you see a right left divide
is because there are leaders in
washington who don't want there to be a
consensus on this issue
i find lots of times whether i go on fox
news or whether i go on wisconsin public
radio
which is left of center by and large
they grouse and they're concerned about
the same thing about corrupt leadership
they might be pointing the finger in a
different direction
but they're talking about corrupt
leadership and what we need to have is a
consensus
number one term limits i know it's been
discussed many times but
if you look at the corrupt behavior that
involves elected officials in washington
dc
it's almost to a person the longer they
stay in power
the more they become seduced by power
the more prone they are to engage in
corrupt behavior so
if you've been in congress for 30 years
the odds are infinitesimally higher
that you're going to engage in corrupt
or extorted behavior
than if you've been there for three
years term limits would be a great way
uh to start second of all a ban on
lobbying by members of congress and
their immediate family members
uh this is a position that has been
supported by
everyone from aoc on the left to ted
cruz on the right
there's another consensus point that i
think would be enormously helpful
because
you would get away from this
self-enrichment model
where elected politicians feel that they
are entitled
they're doing great service to the
country they're irreplaceable but
they're not paid enough they're not
appreciated enough
so it's okay to engage in this sort of
legal graft
where their son or daughter suddenly
becomes a highly paid lobbyist
even though they have absolutely no
expertise there are
areas of consensus the problem is the
left-right divide
prevents us i think from going forward
and addressing some of these issues
that's that's powerful the term limits
and the ban on lobbying members of
congress as well as family both aoc and
ted cruz agree on that
so who doesn't want those two
to pass both term limits and ban on
lobbying who are the people both on the
left and the right said no no no we're
not good we're not we don't want to pass
that
well i think a lot of them i think if
you if you
if you had a open uh uh uh
discussion um uh where they were candid
most elected officials would be opposed
to those pieces of legislation the
problem that they have
is that both of those are supported by
of their constituents so the point is
they don't want to have a debate in this
discussion about it
when the issue of insider trading by
members of congress came up
a bill on that matter had been
introduced years before
and they had had maybe 15 sponsors once
it became public
once it reached critical mass once the
american public
left writing center became outraged and
it became an issue
you suddenly went from having 15
sponsors to more than 300 in the house
of representatives
why did they do that they did it because
they felt they needed to do it or they
were going to
offend enough constituents whereby they
wouldn't be re-elected
so the issue here on term limits and the
ban on
on uh lobbying the real critical issue
is therefore
for there to be a consensus enough to
where elected officials
fear uh that issue and feel like they
have to vote for it or they're going to
lose their jobs
otherwise it's very difficult to get
most
members of congress to do something
that's going to end up
affecting their ability to enrich
themselves and their family
peter can you give some names of who's
against it and who's for it you just
gave two names aoc and ted cruz
that would be for banning lobbying uh
but who's
against you know let's keep term limits
the waiters let's keep lobbying the
waiters can you give us an idea which
camp is which camp
well i would look at the uh leadership
of the house of representatives whether
it's nancy pelosi or steny hoyer
um both of them have been in congress
for decades
uh have never been in favor of term
limits um
their view which i think is wrong is
that
somebody's been in congress has a
certain amount of expertise
uh that's needed um i don't think that's
true at all
um i think there are many qualified
people that can come in and take their
positions
i think if you look at the us senate you
have the same thing i mean there's a
reason
uh senator mitch mcconnell has not
brought a term limits to
uh to the floor uh and does not want to
have it discussed
so again look at the people who have
been in congress for 20 or 30 years
uh they become accustomed to it and the
founders didn't really intend this
uh initially to be in the senate and to
be in the house of representatives
the first hundred years of american
history was kind of seen as a bird
it was kind of seen as something you did
as an obligation
to your community your state and to your
country
uh you're somebody who had success in
farming or as a printer or as a
you know raising horses whatever it was
you ran for office you served for one or
two terms
and you went back to what you did before
uh really beginning
in the 20th century this idea of a
career politician
where you could do good and do well
where you could enrich yourself by
congress that is a relatively new
phenomenon in the united states
and a very very dangerous one so i would
look at
you know probably 75 of both political
parties
in washington dc and elected office
would not want those bills to pass
but i would also say that the vast
majority of them would vote for
it if they believed that their
constituents were fed up
and wanted those pieces of legislation
to pass